-Le coup d'envoie du baccalauréat,
c'est le 11 juin prochain..
..pour 640 000 élèves de terminale.
Pour ceux qui bachotent beaucoup,
..un moment de détente
entre deux annales du bac..
..avec un autre style d'ouvrage,
les perles, qui rassemblent..
..les bourdes.
Comment sont-elles compilées..
..et qu'en pensent
les futurs bacheliers ?
Regardez.
-Terminus pour les terminales.
Dans quelques jours,
..le lycée, c'est fini,
si on décroche..
..son bac, mais quand
on tombe sur ce genre de sujet...
-Quand on ne sait pas,
..on raconte n'importe quoi.
Dans cet ouvrage, un petit
florilège des perles du bac 2006.
-Picasso a représenté
"Les Demoiselles d'Avignon"..
..sous forme de cube,
c'est sa période cubaine.
-Les populations étaient décimées
par la lèpre, la peste..
..et le cholestérol.
-Et à la place du cholestérol,
c'est quoi normalement ?
-De la choléra.
-Des réponses du tac au tac,
..une tactique
qui a ses limites.
-On marque très vite,
..donc on n'a pas le temps
de se relire. Par exemple,
..j'ai vu "violoncelle",
"celle" écrit S.E.L.
-Depuis 10 ans,
Philippe Mignaval récolte..
..les âneries des collégiens
et des bacheliers.
-Plusieurs années de travail..
..à la recherche
du perle du baccalauréat.
-Ces sources : les professeurs
eux-mêmes. Par lettre ou par email,
..ils lui refilent
leurs meilleurs perles.
-Il y a un élève
qui leur dit "bac blanc".
Il a écrit dans sa copie :
.."Le contrat social', c'est un
contrat que Rousseau a signé avec..
"..une assistante sociale
parce qu'il avait trop d'enfants."
-Ce professeur faisait aussi
des bourdes en tant qu'étudiant.
-C'est un souvenir de bac,
un copain qui sort de l'épreuve..
..d'histoire-géographie.
Il y avait un fond de carte..
..où il fallait placer
les pays d'Amérique latine.
Et en étant un "killer",
..en disant : "L'Afrique,
pas de problème, j'ai tout placé."
-Pour ne pas dépasser leur maître,
..les élèves ont encore le temps
de donner un dernier effort..
..afin de ne pas enfiler
les perles le jour du bac.